hi YouTube my name is Tamara chambers
and this is cameras never seen today I
am watching Kill Bill Vol 2 which is odd
because I think Kill Bill Vol 1 it's one
of my favorite movies of all time that's
never yeah I don't know stops to maybe
watch the second of one of my favorite
films of all time so we're going to do
that today
I just tweeted out give me those Kill
Bill 2 predictions can't wait for this
episode heart emoji katana sword emoji
I'm just very excited to do this
reaction video and let's get started
[Music]
I love this film this film pumped me up
in just a wave I don't know that any
other movie ever has ever before ever
they're both incredibly different but in
ways that complement each other one is
definitely always going to be my
favorite out of the tube to upgrade
I love the slow story building it was a
wordier
for sure less intense sword fights for
sure but still really enjoyable I love
the opening monologue where she's
driving in her car I'm gonna kill bill
I love whoever and if he brumis she's so
wonderful she's so wonderful she's still
working he's just my boo and ordinary
guy just a side note I really want to
cosplay El driver in her like white
cartoon kind of archery the coat that
she wears going into the hospital side
note off topic reminding myself Kill
Bill Vol one does such a good job of
establishing this whole story that you
don't know very much about but you're
super onboard anyways to explains the
story for you and I enjoy how they did
it I love that they start off at the
wedding rehearsal and you find out that
she's left bill for a normal life
and that's why they come to take her out
like I know to build bags I still like
him a lot more than Tommy like Bill
Shuster in the head I still like
Fillmore Bill is such an odd character
you don't hate him
I don't I didn't hate him he's like this
villain that you kind of love I really
enjoy the complexity of that cave call
tech city I wrote the story is so
engaging that's hard for me it me who is
not a movie person or critic or anything
to realize how gorgeous the
cinematography is like it's just so
beautiful you get to the theme where you
see buddy who is Bill's brother also one
of the assassination squad people there
in like the desert and it's just
beautiful the sky and the colors that
they captured in the desert and I was
just so into it my brother is like aw
it's so beautiful is it oh yeah it is I
just didn't notice because there's so
much going on I love you so much oh
Thurman is there to take out buddy and
what's up he shoots her in the chest
with what looks like a shotgun that puts
a damper on everything gross all the
spit tobacco Oh I mean she's been shot
before oh my god what does he inject her
with Oh was that not a shotgun was it
just it was literally rock salt what huh
gun oh she's alive look I mean obviously
look good then buddy proceeds to bury
her alive and you get the amazing master
five palm heart explosion the whole
scene and I love it i go into giant
flashbacks that you forget what you were
watching in the first place so buddy
buries her and he goes this is for
breaking my brother's heart
it's very it's just a really dramatic
way to be killed way to kill someone
reason for killing someone and like
final thing that you're going to say to
someone so dramatic and over-the-top is
for letting the milk spoil this is for
being terrible at guitar this is for
including Ike more than me so dope I
wrote down being buried alive would be I
mean obviously just a horrifying
situation to be in but being after and
being able to act that out would be so
fun
oh so you learn about the five palms
exploding heart technique thing and
she's training for years and years with
this master who has incredible hair and
he's got awesome lines of wisdom so my
pathetic little friend is there anything
you can do well it's the woods that
should fear your hand not the other way
around
Tamara has what this point it goes back
to the coffin scene and she's trying to
get out of the coffin and it's crazy to
me that they know how being resourceful
she is and they don't take away for
pocket knife or her flashlights you know
she was gonna get comedy so she she does
the wood punch to punch rocket punch you
know of course and she gets out and I
love the effect where she's like
crawling out and then then it starts to
cave in under her because obviously
there was a full body and like there's a
lot of space now for the dirt to go in I
just wouldn't have thought of that she
started going back a little bit then
crawled out oh that was such a cool like
small detail so the one eyed blonde who
I want to cosplay as comes in to buy the
sword from Buddy and Buddy took the
sword from Puma the bread I feel bad for
buddy honestly like he's just kind of
doing his job and she's just she's mean
it's revealed that Pumas name is Beatrix
kiddo
which is why bill calls her kiddo all
the time I love it what a weird name
then they go to this giant fight which
is really incredible the fighting is not
as frequent in the second movie but just
so good and
I think possibly my favorite point in
the movie is when Beatrix plugs out her
other eye oh my god it was solid guy
then believed her for the black mama to
get and it's just such a fitting end for
that crusty hole next thing I wrote down
is she goes to get bill and oh I forgot
her girl with the lattice god it was so
cool I cannot believe that I forgot but
that was the cliffhanger from what does
she know that her daughter is still
alive
I love that they have like family time
and there's all this tension between her
and bill but she's just so happy for
your daughter it's a picture of Beatrix
next to her daughter's nightstand I also
love the photo it's a photo of Huma
Thurmond just clutching a thing of bread
same-same so she goes to confront him he
shoots her with a truth serum you get a
lot of talking a back story and honestly
this part was awesome and I didn't hate
bill like I thought I would she's just
five heart explosion problem thingy on
him and he walks his five steps and he
dies and not only Duma Thurmond do what
she set out to do she got her daughter
out of it what she thought she thought
she was dead it's so cool I really want
to make on my personal channel I like my
top ten favorite films of all time which
you know out of the ten that I've seen
it should be easy to come up with I've
been saying for a while but that volume
one has been one of my favorites one of
my top three for sure let's look at some
of these prediction prediction you will
like BB yes
her daughter baby she was so stinkin
cute it was nuts perfect casting you
were going to want to practice the
five-point palm exploding heart text
I'm for sure that I already got it
so it will not be what she respected
whoa no I think you're right I was
expecting it to be different than one
but it was a lot slower and less action
even one you will prefer volume one over
volume two I do prefer volume one I just
think she's so bad as much love like a
strong female character just like kickin
butt and uh two was less action less
kicking butt but still I just enjoyed
the heck out of it for sure you'll reach
peaks gay for uma uma is just God she's
such a good actress she's gorgeous
I love she's like just really strong and
like very natural in in the movies you
will wonder how there could ever be a
Kill Bill three yes is that coming soon
I thought I heard something about that
but maybe I made it up but no I guess
it's not going to be a three that's so
weird
maybe bebe will be a bit grown and then
she'll be tricky
you won't like that you will kind of
like what will happen to El driver
ha ha I love that I like it you think
you highly of research
thank you for your predictions I love
doing the predictions thing it's really
fun to hear what you think I will think
of it and usually be completely correct
I'd like to thank my hat's for being in
this and seeking next week I'll do the
fugitive by
[Music]
[Applause]